Älä himoitse, äläkä vääryhdellä, vie mitään lähimmäisesi omaa.
Mikä on heidän omaansa?Älkää me antako vääryhdelle valtaa, koska se vie kyläturmio.
Pienet valheet saavat aikaan suuret harmit. Muistakaamme sanan lasku, pysykää me totuudessa, sehän ei pala tulessakaan.
Ei monta kun, pysytään totuudessa.
"Pysytään totuudessa", kehotti ensimmäinen soittaja, kiitos hänelle.
Ja totuus on nyt se, että tästä alkaa uusi kansanradio.
Eli tervetuloa jälleen mukaan ja matkaan.
Tellä kertaa jakson teemoja ovat esimerkiksi Nuoriso, Sote ja Posti.
Tämän ohelman joukkueen johtajana toimii Koiviston Lauri.
Yhden soittajan mukaan valkoissa talossa on Narri.
Toinen kansalainen taasen toteaa nykymaailman olevan kummelia.
Niin ja, ikävöidäänpä myös venäläistä musiikkia soittoon.
Nyt on aika kuulla urheilukilpailuihin liittyvä ehdotus.
Hei, on asianomaikoilla ollut semmoinen ehdotus noihin, urheilu ja muihin tämmöisiin kisoihin, ku monta kertaa niitä lopullista menestystä odotetaan jo etukäteen, vaan tämmönen vaatimatoehdotus ku vaatimato jätkäki, et tota noini.
Kunnioitetaan kaikkia vastustajia, eikä lähdetäs siltä vaan niinkun hötkyylen, vaan tehdään parhaamme, ja jos se riitää, niin sille voi mittää, mut et pääsijät yritetään, eikä tussit ehkä niin paljon semmoista turhaa.
Tämmönen tapaus siellä.Seuraavaksi suuntaamme postiaiheen pariin, ennen puheluita yksi kirje, jossa lukee näin.
Millaisiksi posti oikein alkaa muuttumaan? Minä sain kerran laskun, jonka eräpäivä oli se päivä, jolloinka se tuli minulle.
Samoin kävi tiliotekirjeelle, se taisi kiertää ympäri Suomen, ennen kuin saapui minulle.
Siinä meni reilut kolme viikkoa.Ystäväni tilasi paketin naapuriläänistä, ja sen tulo kesti viikon.
Kun hän tilasi kerran ulkomailta, niin se tuli jo parissa päivässä.
Tällä tavoin meille kirjoitti kirjäsnyimerkki, mikä tässä oikein mättää?
Meille Kansanradioon voi lähettää kortteja ja muuta perinteistä postiaosoitteeseen:
Kansanradio, PL, 79, 000, 24, yleisradio.
Oon iimetellyt tuota postin kulkuaku. On syksylä syyskuus lähettetty mulle onnettulukortti, mutta ei oo vielä tullu pelille.
On tuo kummallinen tuo posti, mutta se on tämä tällänen, ku niitä on niitä kirjeen aukoasioita tuolla välillä aina.
Ollu, ku oli tuolla Pasilan postillaki, ihmetelti, että mikä tuo lähetys on tuolla nurkas.
Niin, postin, no, siivoo ja ihmetiltä, mikä se on.
No, sanoivat herrooleita, kattokaa, mikä se on.
No, ne vei, se jää.
No, siitä ei kuulunut sen kummempaa, se oli monta kuukautta siellä postin, nurkas vain se lähetys.
Ei muuuuuta, muuuuui.
Salokaupungin Mettä kolmen jätkä pakkasta päivää koko somen kansalle.
Yksens piidoikin syytä kysyy, että, mikä on postin tarkoitus, ja kuka postin omistaa?
Ku itselläki alkaa olemaa 15-30 kilometrien postin palvelle.
Ja kuka tämän määrää, että näin voidaa tehdä, ku se on kuitenkin tärkeä, muodoseus toisesta.
Ja onko tämä isku siihen, että meidän pitäis saada kolta anteennipää, ja mikrosiru otsa, ettei meitä tarvii ku katsoa tervisiä ruutuun, ja näemme mitä postia, ja mikä viranomanne toimittaa.
Eli voisin kutsuu tätä digitaaliseksi aivopesuksi lopolisuja päätepösäkkii.
Mutta sitten herää kysymys siitäkin, että miksi Suomen kansa, jota ymmärtääkseen, edes terveydä oidon tärkeyttää, ikää syntymää kuolemasta katsottuna.
Mutta kaikki haluaa, että tämä jatkuu, tämä alasajo, ja naapurimaihi karkaa meidän hyvät lääkärit ja hoitajat.
Oletteko te nyt vihdoinkin ymmärtäneet, mitä tarkoittaa eurooppalainen kokonaisuus siitä, mitä teille on puhuttu, tai mitä se kirjasta luetaan Suomen kansalle ymmärrettämäksi?
Tämä on varsinainen uudenlainen vallankääntö, jossa teidän aivopesuja muutetaan, vaat köyhiksi ja ryöstetään.
Näin tulee Suomelle tapahtumaan.
Ja toinen mielenkiinto on tämä kaivosalueten toiminta, tuolla eräällä suunnalla Suomessa kaivos muutetaan, vedellä täytettäväksi.
Oletteko miettinyt koskaan semmoistakin ilmiötä, että jos siitä tuleikin vesipaattia, jorkaa rupea vaikuttaa ja hajortamaan sitten ympäristössä olevia maa-aineksia?
Totushan on se, että sinne on piilotettu ydinjätettä, jota ei kerrota.
Kyseisellä alueella myös haudattiin kaatopaikalle, joka on ennen suljettua, lopetettuja, päitetta.
Ne vietiin järvistä pyydettyjä, kaloja haisemaa, ettei niitä tarvinu parantaa vedessä olevien kalojen määrätä.
Onko meistä hölmäläistä tullu vieläkin tyhmempi, ku mitä kirja- tai sanakaapesti kertoa? Toivottavasti suutuutte, kiitos.
No nyt ei ole aikaa suuttua, kun tieme vie lapsuutta ja nuoruutta käsittelevien ajatusten maailmaan.
Aloitetaan jälleen kirjeellä.
Hei, kansanradio, olen 79-vuotias mummo, en tiedä enkä ymmärrä kaikkea, vaikka elämä on paljon opettanut.
Ihmettelen, kun ihmiset laittavat purukumin suuhun, ja puhuvat, että syövät purkkaa.
Eihän sitä syödä, kuka sen nielee vatsaansa?
Jos pussissa lukee purukumia, niin eikö sitä purra?
Muutenhan paketissa lukutaitoisen mielestä lukisi syömäkumia.
Pitäisikö olla puheessa varovaisia lasten kuulen?
Pian pienet maat ovat täynnä purukumia, kun luulevat syömäkumiksi.
Näin siis luki kansanradion saapuneessa kirjeessä.
Orpo haluaa, että lapset liikkuu, ja kaikki liikkuu.
Oikei hyvä asia.
Mutta ensisijainen asia olisi ravinto.
Aivan hirvittäviä hintoja.
Hedelmät, vihannekset, ehdottomasti marjat.
Näiden hintaa pitää saada alemmas.
Se on meinaa semmoinen juttu, että ne jää kyllä sieltä, kaupasta ostamatta, pienituloisilta, jopa keskituloisilta.
Ja kun näitä ei opita, syömään lapsesta asti, ne jäävät pois. Hei.
No juu, se on Palmo Antti Kankeselta hyvää päivää, kun soittelee.
Hyvää päivää.
Näni en ihmettele yhtään tätä nuorison meluomista, ja siis tätä tappelua ja tappoja, koska nämä 80 ja 90 on mulla syntyneet vanhemmat, on tämän vapaan kasvatuksen tuloksia.
Niin ei oo ihme, jos tota nuoriso riahuu, sieläsuu täällä, kun vanhemmat ei tajua mitää.
Ni, että vanhemmista se on kiinnit, tää nuoriso käyttäytymene.
No, no, 90 resettiesti.
Mitän oot päättynyt tähän mielipiteeseen, tähän kantaan?
Ei tartte, ku kattelee leht, päivittäisiä lehtiä, taikka kuuntelee radio, radio mulla on melkei koko päivän auki.
Ei voi muuhun tulokseen tulla, ku silloin kauheesti palastettiin tästä vapaasta kasvatuksesta.
Nyt on yks sukupolvi jo ohi, nyt näkee nuorisossa sitten, että mitä on.
Miten tästä päästaisiin parempaan tilanteeseen?
Pikkuisen vanhemmille vastuuta. Tää on totuus asiassa, mikä on, ja mille ei, nyt se on vaikee tehdä mitään, koska tota, tää vapaa kasvatus on tehnyt tämän tuloksen.
Selvä juttu, kiitoksia paljon tästä puhelusta ja oikein hyvää sunnotajatkoa.
Kiitos samoja, moi.
Seuraavat soittajat kommentoivat monipuolisti aiempien jaksojen aiheita. Aloitamme oikaisulla. Vuosiluvut ovat tärkeitä.
Tas oi Juhani Terve, mä et ois edellisessä kansanradiossa, mä huomasin semmoisen virheen, kuiks mies soitti, et sä ois, ku sä muijenset kanssa luodet rintaa vuonna.
1990, niin mä huomasin korrataista, ettei ollut 1990, vaan se oli vuonna.
1989, okei, kiitos, ei mitää, moi moi.
No, joku mies arvosteli viime pyhänä Aleksanteri Stuppia presidenttiä ja pääministeri Petteri Orpoaniini, kyllä ne minusta on nii tyylikkästi pukeutuvat, ja Tuppikin on semmone urheilinen ja hoikaniini, kyllä sitä kehtaa.
Tää monen valtiopäämiehen vieressä, että mä ihmettelee, ja varmaan niinkun presidenti Linnakiini ohjeistaa ja seuraa niiden pukeutumista, että ei ne missää valintotalon rääsyissä kulje, olis kiva tietää, että miten tää soittaja pukeutuu, ei muuta, hei hei.
Täällä 80 plus, eräs nishenkilö soitti ja pyysi, kuinka hän saa vaikeelle mielenterveyspotilaalle omaiselle apua, ja minä sanon nyt, että kriisiryhmä on ainakin Tampereella olemassa.
En tiedä numeroa, mutta kriisiryhmä tulee auttaan, ja ratkaisee ongelmia. Tämän omaisen puolesta kriisiryhmä on olemassa, ja heille voi pyytää, että he tulee auttaa. Heippa.
No semmoista asiaa, kun joku nainen valitti siellä, että televisiosta tulee vaan noita uusintoja ja uusintoja niini, olisi kiva tietää, että, tää kyseinen soittaja niini, maksaako hän paljon yleveroa vai, onko vapautettu kokonaan, saa ilmaiseksi katsoa telkkaria, ei muuta, hei hei.
Laitapuolen pörsäkö tässä vaan, ja päivää, arvoisat huijat. Minä tässä vaan haluan antaa herrasmiehenä tuki lausumaan sille nishenkilölle, joka puhui valittajista.
Hemmoisia ne on suurin osa, aina vaan, että sössön sössön, ja vali vali. Mutta mistä tuun, että ystävän?
Miettikääpä sitä, pörsäke kiittää ja kumartaa, heipa hei.
No päivää, Lauri, tätä, muuan huuhentaalinainen soittelee.
Päivää, päivää.
Minä tossa ilahtuneena kuutelin tämän päiväistä kansanradiota, ja kuulostaa siltä, että, tämä katajani kansa alkaa ni ku pikku hiljaa heräämään tuota unesta, ja siellä on sangenviisaita lausumia, kuulee.
Mikä erityisesti jäi mieleen?
No, erityisesti tämä Kainuista soittanut. Herrasmies, joka kuvaili tätä, herra, Amerikan presidenttiä, ja, mitenkäs sanoo, että tämä pitäisi laittaa tämmönen narsismin palkinto.
Joo, näin olee.
Joo, nii tuli vaan mieleen sit, että, että siinä aika hyvin tuli kuvattua, kun luen jonkin verran tuotakei hengelistä kirjallisuutta, tunnetuinta maailmatunnetuinta kirjaa, niin, siinä tuli mieleen eräs kuvaus tuota, antikristuksesta.
Joo.
Et, kuikahan on röhkeä kasvoilta, ja saa kaiken menestymään, kuitenkin ilman omaa voimaansa. Mutta, kyllähän näitä niin sanottuja antikristuksia on läpi maailman ollut, mutta, kyllä tää aika korostuneesti tulee ni ku esille, tämä hänen persoonansa tässä.
Siehen, sillä on kyllä tietenkin pyrkimiskin, tai saada kaikki kumartamaan itsiään, itsiänsä tavalla tai toisella, mutta, paljon, paljon muitakin hyvin heränneitä ja viisaita, todella viisaita ajatuksia, olin hyvin iloinen, ja voisi sanoa, että, kun he puhuvat siläänestä vaaliehdokkaista ja kansanedustajista, että, hyviä ehdotuksia, niin, ennen se valittiin silleen, että, ehottaja ensin, siellä ois oikein hyviä kansanedustajia ehdokkaita, sitten, täällä kansanradion linjoilla, että, ei, muuta, kun näyttämää sitten sitten,
tota mallia, että, miten sitä kansaa edustetaan, ja eikä anneta minkään ison maailman agendojen itseä taivuttaa, vaan pidetää omaa pintamme, niin eiköhän se siitä se alkaisi rotii muuttumaan.
Kiitoksia paljon tästä ehdotuksesta, ja mukava silään tarjatkoa, kiitos samoin.
Kiitos, samoin, joo, heippa.
Äskenen soittaja jo väläytti tulevaa aihetta, sillä seuraavaksi haukkaamme jälleen palan maailman politiikan kakkua.
Kiitoksia just kuuntelin uutisia, että, rumppi painostaa, mutta minun mielestä hän kiristää.
Onko se tuolla herrojen kielessä vähän niinku, siellä ei olla nii, hankaria.
Hei, eikös valkoista taloa voi kutsua niinkun, se on hovi, ja hovissa aina on hovinarri, eikö näin, voi?
Joo, helke täällä.
Semmonen asiani, että, se on Amerikassa on keisari.
Ja, ettäkö te, Eurooppa jo tajuani, että nyt ollaan kuule menossa semmosen aikaan, että, ko keisari hallittee.
YK on nolla, ja keisari perustaa oman lakikirjan, ja Suomen kansanedustajistakin, siellä on semmosia, jotka kehuu sitä vielä, tätä alaikästä hullua.
Sehän suomalainen ministeri kehuu, että, se on hyvää tuo rumppi, hävetkää, Suomen kansanedustaja, äkkiä vaihtoo semmoinen ministeri, ja hep.
Ja hep, sanoi helke, vanhan totuuden mukaan, jos äskeiset puhelut kuuluvat mustikkakategoriaan, niin seuraavat ovat sitten mansikkalaarista.
Ennen audioviestejä, yksi teksti, joka on lähdetty kansanradion verkkosivujen lomakkeella.
Minua ihmetyttää, kun Suomesta ollaan jatkuvasti lähettämässä avustuspaketteja Ukrainaan.
Eikö olisi jo aika lopettaa velkarahalla avustaminen?
Eihän näillä ministereillä näytää olevan hitustakaan järkeä.
Tämä teksti oli lähdetty kansanradion verkkosivujen lomakkeella, sen oli kirjoittanut nyymerkki, havukkahon ajattelija.
Sähköpostilla. Kansanradion sähköpostiosoite on kansan.radio@yle.fi.
Sohjeesee Oulusta, ja tämmöstä asiaa haluaisin sanoa, että ku, mii se on tänään, ku, vaikka vaan talous on mennyt tänne kuralen, ni ku on menny, ni, tuota.
Ei kuka enää edes puhu, että otan poliittisen vastuu, minne on kavonnut se kuulusa poliittinen vastuu, ku, siitä ei kukaan puhu, tänään, mitä.
Tämä oli mun sano, jo, hei.
Itärajatinnosta.
Hyvää päivää.
Päivää päivää.
Ihmettelen tätä, maailman menovakotuta, kansanedustajat ja nää päättäjät on seitsemän kuukautta, vaan töissä vuodesta, ja sitten sotaa tuolla muissa maissa.
Rampit ja nää on, tuota, koko ajan tapetilla, ja tuota, omat porukat, kansanedustajat, kaikki jo lomilla, monta kuukautta.
Ni viittaat, tää eduskunnan istuntotaukoa, vai?
Joo, ne on taivoil kaikki, ne, tuota, seitsemän kuukautta vuoteen, työelämässä, ei ne, ne on lomilla, kaika.
Sit, jos joku hätää sattuu tulemaan, ni siitä hyökkäävät, vasta, ei ne, ne on lomilla, ei ne tee mitää.
Eli, oletko sitä mieltä, että kansanedustajilla ei pitäis olla istuntotaukoja ollenkaan?
Ei, noi pitkiä, istuntotaukoja, katokku, tuota, tässä tilanteessa, nyt ollaan sellaisessa tilanteessa, nyt pitäis olla päättäjä, niinku päästämässä tuota, tuota, tuota, tuota, tilanne on aika vakava jo nyt, te.
Mutta, kuitenkin, nyt, tässä ihan viime aikoinakin, niin, ainakin ulkoasienvaliokuntaan on kokoontunut.
Nii, on aine kokoontuna, mut tuota, ei oo kaikki kokoontuna, kyllä ne on lomilla.
Sit, tuossa meriliikenteessä nyt, venäläiset, sirveet, määrät, aluksia kulkee, yks kerrä, kopama, tai joku onnettomuus, ni siinä onkin tietämistä.
Eli, siis ehdospunnan istutotauot lyheimmäksi on sinun ehdotuksen?
Nii, lyheimmäks pitäis saaha, ei se, tuolla päättäjät, katot, tuota, ku olla lomilla, sit, mikä hässäkka sattuu, ni sit vasta tapahtuu, jotai, ei taho tapahtua mitää.
Tätä Suomen työlisyyttä, ku joka puuta lyvyää pois, tää latterastakin lyvyää.
Tääntäki on lyötynä, ni huissi, seitsemä, kaheksasta henkeen lyötynä.
Loma, tuota, on näin tuolla lopputilit ja kaikki, ni ku tehtaatopannaa, spannaa Kiina ja kaiket.
Silvi, Yttu, kiitoksia paljon näistä ajatuksista ja tästä ehdotuksesta.
Mukalvela sunnotaa jatkoa sinulle.
Joo, sitä samaa sullei.
Hei, hei.
Se on lastitaastelta hälsinti Alppyhädystä.
Rupesin tuossa kasvamaan tuota erikoista tapausta, kun kansanedustaja, joka varasialla, ei voi kieltäytyä ottamasta kansanedustajan virkaa, koska on päässyt toiseen tehtävään, josta tuntuu pitävään.
Sieä kansanedustajia on ihan tarpeksi, jotka on siellä poissa, niin miksei tällaisen henkilö, joka aitaisi eteenpäisen tehtävään ja anneta olla irti sitä hommasta, koska niitä kansanedustajia muutenkin hymyää ties, missä olematta työn paikallansa.
Ku, tässä eduskunta kuullaan päättää sen.
Mitä eduskunta silloin päättää toisen puolesta, onko tämä diktatuuri valtio, kun täällä päätetään toisten puolesta?
Ei muuta.
Kysyn vain.
Morjens.
Morjens sinne Alppiharjuunkin, ja näin olemme siirtyneet soteteeman hellään huomaan.
Enen seuraavaa soittajaa on aika lukea postikortti.
Nyt, kun tulee se tunnin juna, tunnissa pääsee Turusta Hesaan ja puolivälin kaupunkeihin puolessa tunnissa, eikö sieltä voisi sulkea terveysasemia, päivystyksiä ja ehkä sairaaloitakin.
Siellä olisi lyhkäset matkat, toista on täällä Pohjois-Savossa.
Tällä tavoin ottiin kantaa postikortissa, jonka kuvassa on talvinen puromaisema.
80+ kysyy, että onko niillä ajokorttitarkastus lääkäreillä, joka ei siis oo enää terveyskeskukslääkäreitä, vaan muita.
Oikeus mennää, sinne omakantaan katsoo kaikki tiedot ihmisiltä, että mun mielestä, jos menee ajokorttia uusimaan, niin se täytyy olla se hinta, mitä ne sanoo etukäteen, ja se täytyy saada maksaa heti.
Et ei tuu mitää yllätyslaskuja, kahden viikokuluttoa, minä vaan kysyn.
No, hyvää päivää täältä, Etelä-Pohjanmalta, Härmänmailta.
Täällä on eräs omaishoitaja, eläkeläinen kylläkin.
Olen itse lonkkaleikkauksen tähden jonossa, ja se jono kestää kuukausia, kivut kestää kans kuukausia.
Ja omaishoitajan pitäis saada sukat omeha, ja toisenkin jalkha, ja paljon muutakin.
Mistä se johtuu, että nää jonot on niin pitkiä?
Vai yritetäänkö meidät iäkkäämmät, vaikko olis omaishoitajakin, niin jotenki kiruttamalla saada pois päiväjärjestyksestä, ja nuorempia leikataan?
Vai eikö ole leikkaajia, vai eikö ole paikkoja, missä leikataan, mistä se kiikastaa? Kiitoksia, heippa.
Olen morjastama saa täällä jälleen, tota nii, maa, etel tästä näin vaan, olen onnellinen, sitä, ko Suomi on ollut monta kertaa onnellisen ja rauhallisen maa.
En hän huomaa tosta, koska Suomessa on Euroopan eniten työttömiä asukas lukuun nähden.
Ja sitten näitte vanhusten hoito, koska usiampi viikko löytyi melkein hirttosolmukassa löytyypi, niinkuin Turussakin löytyi vanhus kuolleena.
Ja niinkarumissakin hakattiin vanhusta, ja niin ympäri Suomia hakataan vanhuksia, että kyllä tää on tosi tosi onnellinen maa.
Ja näitä luikureita, ja tämmösiä katupumppareita, ni pitkin katuenää nuorisot visvailevat vain, ja vapaa kasvatusta, vapaa kasvatusta,
ja pitemmät terää aseet vain nuorisolle, ni hyvin pyrhkii Suomella, ja olemme onnellisia ja onnellinen maa.
Ja kun, tässä tautetaan kysymys näin jostain vanhuhten kodista, ja miksi näin muorille kävi?
No tää on yksityistapaus, vaan, anteeksi, vaan tää on yksityistapaus, ettei tässä mitää nähtää oo edelpää.
Mutta yksi neuvolismulla, mitä muutako, usiampi vanhus kerrallani ei oo enää yksityistapaus.
Oikein paljon, kansanradiolle, kansanradioon, Suomen paras ohkelma, Lauri juontaa hyvin sitä.
Terveisin, Suomi on onnellinen maa. Annuksille hoitova, ja hirtosilmukkia kirävämmälle vaan. Hei paneijaa.
Tuula täällä päivää. Tuolta mä tuosta vanhosten hoidosta, että kun niitä sinne kotiin yritetää hoitaa semmoisia, jotka eivät todellakaan enää pärjää siellä.
Siinä ei oo mitään järkeä, että siellä se hoitaja menee sinne pitkiä matkoja, ajeilee eri paikkoihin, että se hoitajan aika menee siinä autossa istuessa.
Ja sitten tämä nettihomma, että nyt laitetaan nettihoitaja, siellä jossakin netin äärestä, ja sitten niille vanhuksille, jotka eivät osaa käyttää niitä nettejä ja robotteja, mitä sinne tehdään.
Et miksi ihmeessä ei voida tehdä semmoisia hoitokoteja? Itseasiassa niitä on olemassa, monessa kunnossa on tyhjillään hyviä kiinteistöjä, johonka voisi nämä vanhukset tuoda, ja siellä oli se hoitaja, ja se hoitaisi siinä lähellä, eikä netin kautta niitä.
Ei mitään muuta, kiitos.
Leevientö Liimix laulaa onnellisesta laulussaan erilaista kodinkoneista. Seuraavaksi nostetaan keskiöön televisio ja radio.
Ennen puheluita kerron, että kansaradion jakso ilmestyy Yle Areenaan, joka perjantai kello 21.
Jos merkkaat sydämen kuvasta ja tilatoihelmasta ilmoitukset kellon kuvasta, niin saat aina ensimmäisenä tiedon, kun uusi jakso ilmestyy Yle Areenaan.
No, Marti, sä tervehtis, kuosa iimetellyt tuota Ylen hommaa, että ku alta se uutiskanava oli ratiotaattelvä, ni se o aina Usaa.
Ka, onko se Yle muuttunu Usaan pääkanavaksi? Ohan täällä Suomassakin paljon asioita.
Esimerkiksi vaikka tona STP käpäilöntihelma, mutta eipä sitä varmasti toimittijät halua puhua, ku sehän voi sattua omaan nelikkaan.
Ei muuta.
Olen surullinen, että korvat on molemmat.
Nen nyt? No, kuuleehan sitä aina vähän, mutta kyllä nykyään unelmoin siitä, vanhana, niistä venäläisistä slaavilaisista, kauniista lauluista, jota mun äitini kerran soitti ja lauloi.
Nitähän ei enää kuule, valitettavasti, mutta semmoinen vaan tuli mieleen.
Sanja Poikelopuhelimessa haluan kiittää Arja saijoamaan konsertista. Se oli kyllä mukava kuunnella.
Ja olen kuunnellut ki monta kertaa tallennuksesta. Tämmöstä ku oli se enäämpi. Kiitos.
Sirpa tässä moi. Viime lähetyksessä nishenkilö kuvasi Radio Suomen musiikkia naaraskissojen naukumiseksi.
Olen ihmetellyt samaa jo monta vuotta.
On mainostettu, että ylellä on Suomen suurin levyhylly.
Miksi? Tästä levyhyllystä soitetaan vain yhdestä kohtaa.
Elin niitä lapsen äänellä vinkuvia naislaulajia.
Kun tiedetään, että Radio Suomen kuuntelijoista pääosa on noin viiskyt plusvuotiaita.
Niin pitäisi soittaa muutakin musiikkia kuin 2020-luvulla tehtyä, vaihidellen jopa eri vuosikymmeniltä.
Nuorisolle on jo useita radiokanavia, heidän musiikkinsa ei saisi vallata radiosuomea, mutta niin on käynyt.
Suostuin kuuntelemaan sitä naukumista silloin tällöin, mutta en koko päivää.
Eläkeläinen soittelee täältä sivistyksen parista Tampereelta, hei.
Nyt ku on tuota aikaa kuunnella tuota radiosuomea, mutta ku on, sit on tullutki kaikuradio.
Se toistaa itseänsä niin pirusti, varsinkin nämä nykyään lähellä sinua osiot.
Uutisia, jotka on tullut pari minuuttia sitten, ja sitten omia nimia.
Minä olen se toimittaja, minä olen se toimittaja, minä olen se toimittaja, ja kellonaikoja.
Kyllä voit hiukan muuttaa tuota käytäntöä paremmaksi.
Täältä näin. Hyvää kevään jatkoa. Morjens.
Karitaat kotkas tuota.
Iks ei radio enää tussi tohvan, mikä oli ennen.
Piisaisten kerho, ni siinäkin aina näittivät kysymyksiä, siellä niiden vastata.
Ni se ois mukava, jos se tuli suurelle semmoinen viisaisten kerho-ohjelma radioon.
No, Lizo täällä taas, morjesta.
Moi, moi.
Semmoinen asia ensistää, tämmönen on aikaisemminkin tullut kansanradiossa, kun TV1 tekstitys, niin kun se ei näyt.
Metrin päähän.Mutta MTV-kanavalla, se on valkosella pohjalla, se tekstitys, ja sen näkee jo kahden ja puolen metrin päästä, hyvin pystyy lukemaan.
Tä semmoinen asia olis niikun, ensistään olit tässä.
Selvä homma, kovasti ratisee nyt, puhelin, mutta TV1 kaipaat parempaa tekstitystä.
Joo, kyllä.Mutta, mutta sitten mul oli kyllä runopätkäkin.
No, ole hyvä.
Trampin ja Puutkinin metallit, diili, sodan lo, jo hiipi.
Tallit, jäet tans tasaan, moleimmile oma kasa, siinä on vakuus ja turvatakuu.
Ette semmoinen juttu olis.
Kiitoksia, paljon taas Lissu runosta.
Hyvää päivänjatkoa sinne, ja hyvää tätä uutta vuotta.
Kiitoksia teille lähetyksestä.
Sitä samaa, hei hei.
Kiitos, hei hei.
Siinä kuultiin Lissulta runo.
Kohta kuullaan lisääkin lyriikkaa.
Sitä ennen seuraavalla soittajalla ei vissiin ole oikein mitään asiaa, mutta ennen häntä vielä tämä WhatsApp-viesti.
Hei, kansanradio. Minua on alkanut sapettamaan nämä koiran ulkoiluttajat.
Miksi koira pitää tuoda postilaatikon kohdalle tai portin pieleen tarpeilleen, vaikka katua tai tietä on mittaamattomasti.
Ei ole mitenkään ihanaa hakea postia laatikosta, jonka juurella on keltainen tai ruskea terveinen.
Tapa on sama, oli kaupunki tai pikku kylä.
Eras ulkoiluttaja sai primitiivisen reaktion, kun kysyin, että jos mä tulen sun portin pieleen paskalle, rupesi uhkailemaan.
Viestin oli lähettänyt meille Jusa Hämeestä WhatsApp-sovelluksen kautta.
Meille kansanradioon voi lähettää WhatsApp-viestejä, sekä tällaisia tekstimuotoisia kommentteja,
että myös ääniviestejä, joita niitäkin on muuten pari kappaletta mukana tässäkin ohjelmassa.
Kansanradion WhatsApp-numero on 044-551-5464.
Mutta minä aina tuota, ku saan jonku uuden numeron raatiosta tai TV:stä tai näistä.
Minä soittelen jokkaiseen numeroon, mutta ei sitä, mitä hyötyy, päi haitto.
Eleikkarin kuvat puheidenlaskot on tän. Toista tonni oli viimekin vuonna.
Tän, minä tätä soittamista lopeta, vaikka ei ne julukasekkaan näitä.
No, nyt näköjään, tämäkin tuli julkaistua.
Mutta, nyt on aika Olavin valmistautua runoonsa.
Häntä ennen kerron vielä kansanradion puhelinnumeron.
Se on 08-00-1-5-4-6-4.
Ja puhelu on soittajalle maksuton.
Ja muistuksena, että sunnuntaisin kello 12.30 alkaen, tuossa numerossa vastaa, ihmis vastaa ja kolmen tunnin ajan.
Alamisoittelee hyvää päivää, luen runooni sitten joskus ja kun.
Näinhän usein ihmiset suunnittelee.
Sitten joskus ja kun.
Sitten matkustelen, maailmaa katselen, sitten teen, minä tuon ja sen.
Sitten toimeen tartutaan.
Tee jo heti, tänään tai huomenna.
Älä mieti joskus ja kun.
Se voi haaveeksi jäädä kokonaan, eikä unelmas haaveesi toteudukaan.
Olavi.
Säpinää, on ainakin vielä luvassa tässä jaksossa.
Ennen viimeisiä puheluita, minä toivotan teille kaikkea hyvää.
Koiviston Lauri kiittää ja kumartaa.
Kansanradio, jälleen viikon päästä.
No terve, kansanradioon.
Nyt on kyllä säpinää, kansanradion aalloilla.
Ni kuin maukkaperut, jätkän laulussa.
Säpinää, säpinää.
Myö meininki, antaa pala ja mielipiteet, paukku.
Nähän ollaan kohta nii kuin Iranin kansa.
Vähdetään kanuret muuttamaan, vaatimaan muutoksia.
Ellei sitten poliitikot sulje tätä, kansanradiota.
Mutta jatketaan samaan malliin, nii kauan ku pystytään.
Heippa!
No niin, Mauno Vautilainen, Kelan eläkkeellä.
Niin, ennen oli tämä kummeliohjelma sieltä Tampereelta, Toholopista.
Oli kovaa sanaa ennen kummeli, mutta nyt on nämä uutiset.
Kummelia uutiset ovat tulleet kummelin tilalle.
Amerikan kummeli tämä trumpetti, ja sitten tämä mörkkytäpiö, Poutleri ja Vektori, Orpana, näin.
Mutta tuota kummeliahan tämä on, lyhyesti sanottuna.
Nyt, jäät kestää pelkille ja heistämään ja luistelemaan jäälle, näin, kiitoks.
Mummeli täällä, entä mitää kummaa tiedä, no saretta, en yhtään siedä.
Pitää varmaan takki vaihtaa, pakkasia tarkoin kaihtaa.
Lupasivat kylmää yöksi, letäileminen jääkin työksi.
Hyvä yöte.
Hei kaikki kansanradiolaiset, olipa ihana päästä lapsen lapselle opettamaan Persmäen laskua.
Se vaan harmittikö oli liian pieni pulkka, ettemme molemmat mahtuneet siihen.
Nimimerkillä.